when I was in Atlanta and I was hanging
out with you guys for a day and we were
shooting some promotions actually I
don't think you were there Shaq they
were bad-mouthing you they were saying
you don't give you don't go out and buy
them presents at Christmas time you give
them products you get for free that you
endorse is that true hundred percent
true oh oh you know how you like you
wrap your Christmas presents up for kids
yeah you don't have to do that we just
look at the commercials on doing our
show we're like well I guess I know what
we did this year if that might be the
cheapest billionaire we know yeah but
Charles is the most invented because one
year I gave him a Christmas present
and so then Mother's Day came around
he's like all I didn't get your wife
anything from I got this great bag in my
locker for I want you get rings the brow
set that's the bag I gave you last year
so he we got cheap and the bad regifter
I'm a battery grifter a gift sir I did I
did I gave his wife a lovely it was a
beautiful bag though but it was the bag
I gave you for Christmas but I wasn't
going to use it
it's in a woman's bag you gave thought
it was a luggage there's a very nice
luggage bag without you know it said I
love you honey on alright we'll check
your you got to admit you've got a
lot of endorsement deals you've got
let's take just a brief look of some of
the things it's Aquila II know there's
these Shaquille O'Neal collection let's
just go through these quickly Fruity
Pebbles gotta get those kids there's
your icy hot keep going we got a lot of
them
there's a curio there watching I keep
going there's punch you just made
$600,000 when he gives us one of those
gifts he tries to explain it came out of
the budget they'll come out the bunch so
technically he paid for exactly where it
came out of the budget you you gave it
an icy hot you say explain this to him
yes as a company I order a hundred
thousand uh-huh and I gift for I still
pay for the hundred thousand hey thanks
for watching be sure to click subscribe
to see even more great Conan clips you
may now return to your pirated movies
and creepy Japanese pornography